[Music]
hello everybody
thank you so much for hanging out here
with me my name is alex castillejos
and today here in just be blessed we
share hope
we share love and we share people's
testimonies and have left
messages and how god is good
and tonight i have a very special guest
is david machado that's right
and he is share
the gospel of jesus christ uh through
the united states and i'm sure
international and let me tell you we're
gonna find out about his life
growing up uh in the christian home by
the way in the christian home
it was some circumstances that it was
without
his control growing up uh it was some
drugs reviews it's gonna uh we're gonna
find out more about his life and let me
tell you this is a live show and do my
favor
uh share this link because i know uh uh
there are gonna be people they're gonna
be blessed just listening
his testimony his life and
please share this link because you know
there's a lot of stuff and social media
let's bring some positive depth and
let's bring some hope
to this crazy world all right so let's
invite him okay
listen my brother david how you doing
bro davey thanks so much for being here
and just be blessed
thank you for having me i'm so excited
to be here with you all
great great uh i know it was it was kind
of like
uh uh you know i follow you in social
media
and i was like i'm gonna ask him you
know maybe he has a testimony
right and i remember i i sent a message
and and i was like yeah i have a
testimony and when you share the little
description
of your testimony i was like whoa
i i i'm so excited
to hear to know more about about you
because i mean i don't have that
relationship with you i just just follow
you in
instagram and i know you you share you
know uh
the gospel revelation seminars
and all the stuff so and i'm very
excited right now
uh thanks so much seriously i really
appreciate it
absolutely thank you for having me yeah
so to find out
about more about you and uh
how was growing up i mean you you
sharing a little description that
about your life it's like uh you grew up
in a christian home but
we want to find out how was home bros
and sisters
everything was wonderful jesus was at
home
what's up
yeah i actually have some pictures that
i'll share with you
my little childhood and where i grew up
right here on on the screen my my
parents met in the church
they were christians um my father's
mexican my mother's puerto rican
and they met at church and they gave
birth to myself
and my little sister her name is
christina and
it's about three and a half four year
gap between us and um
it was wonderful i mean you know this is
our family portrait
this is the only one of the only
pictures that i found where my whole
family's actually
together because you're gonna find out
in just a little bit what happened
to this to this family um but
it was a wonderful home a loving home um
you know my parents loved my sister and
i they still do and
and even though we grew up going to
church and and
singing hymns and doing all these things
i have to be completely honest with you
that my
my god was not jesus christ it was
basketball
my father is a die-hard los angeles
laker fan
and so naturally i just whatever my
father loved i loved and so
from a very young age he handed me a
basketball and i would play basketball
i would i would dream about basketball
basketball was my life
i wanted to become a professional
basketball player and i honestly was
looking forward to to being
one of you know playing in in the
staples center in los angeles
and and that was my dream in life
because
very early on i had a very um i had
quite a traumatic experience and
later on i guess in my in my testimony
and sharing with you i could kind of get
into what happened but
usually around the age of around the age
of five or six years old
everything was going well i was loving
life loving my parents and
when i was about five or six years old
my parents happened to get a divorce
and that's where things turned bad very
quickly
um after that divorce things didn't
didn't go well at all wow i'm so sorry
to hear that you know i mean
and what you mentioned i mean you're
sharing this you know beautiful picture
you know and a child
uh with her with his parents and the
beautiful girl you know
your sister and when you share the
it was the only picture that i can
remember i mean that i
i have with me the the four of us that
were together i mean that's a little
tough man i mean just to hear i mean
just to see the picture but that was the
picture like
way long time ago you know it was not
like five years ago
yeah and and the reason why that was the
only
family picture i guess that i was able
to find was
because of the divorce in such an early
age um
we you know things really took a turn
for the worse after that yeah
after my parents got divorced um i
i lived with my mother for for a number
of short years
and unbeknownst to my mother um
my she had some family members that were
addicted to drugs
and i remember one night i was
you know we were sleeping in an
apartment that my mother was sharing
with one of her family members
and it was my mom my sister and i
sleeping on the same bed and the other
family member was
on the opposite side of the apartment in
his own room
and i just remember one night i just was
kneeling down to go to bed and
just saying my prayers and all of a
sudden um
as i was kneeling down right there by
the bedside to pray i heard a voice say
david get out
just a huge very clear impression
saying david get up and get out and
it was it was like a man's voice and
there was no man in the room so i
immediately opened up my eyes and
i looked at my mom and i said did you
hear that she was like no
what do you mean did i hear what i said
some man someone said to get out
and she said mijo our son it's gonna be
okay just just get in bed
it's gonna be all right and i remember i
just got into bed with my mother and my
sister and fell asleep fairly quickly
and
to this day this was you know 27 eight
years ago
i still remember this i was sleeping on
the bed i fell asleep and i had this
dream where there was lots of angels
flying around saying david get up
david get out david get up david get out
and i remember waking up
to screaming and yelling there was this
this
the atmosphere that we were breathing
was polluted by
the smell of drugs and and i could hear
my family member right there in the
living room
screaming and talking in different
voices and it was
hugely dramatic and i remember i look
over to my sister she's crying my
mother's crying she says david go lock
the bedroom door
i run over there lock the bedroom door i
i run back because i'm obviously scared
we escaped through the bedroom window we
run
over to uh one of someone in the same
apartment complex that my mother knew
and from just a short distance away i
could hear my family member yelling and
screaming
and all of a sudden i heard this big
bang and this family member ended up
breaking the our bedroom door and
screaming where
are you i'm going to kill you where are
you i'm going to kill you
so he wasn't so like an influence i mean
i mean or are you just demon possessed i
mean what happened
well he he was under the intoxication of
drugs
he was doing some hardcore drugs and i'm
sure some other things but it was
it was definitely something i never seen
in my life i heard different voices i
heard
demonic things if you will and it was
all because of the drugs that he was in
and so from a very early age i'm talking
about
six years old i've had to escape from
the bedroom window several times because
a family member was trying to kill us
i i i would literally have seen
some of my family beat their own sibling
almost to death
right before my very eyes and so i as a
little boy
i i was just quite aware of the danger
even with family and
several times having to to to run for my
life
wow i'm sorry
i mean i mean that's that that is not a
a childhood for a child for a child
right i mean yeah so
yeah i definitely wouldn't wish it upon
anyone and
you know finally i thought things were
gonna get a little bit better my
my mother ended up getting her own
apartment complex and so
i thought man our problems are now over
uh we no longer have to live with anyone
else we're safe in our own little bubble
now and i was just happy i was just
thankful
your life was gonna get better and i
remember one day
life's starting to get a little better
we were having our own house we had our
own space so i could run around
i could go to bed at peace knowing that
nothing bad was gonna happen
but one day something did happen um my
mother i remember this to this day
she handed me a cookie she said david
it's time to to go
and so i was the first one out the door
i mean you give you give your child
something sweet they're gonna leave you
know they're gonna do whatever you want
so my mom gave me a cookie i was so
happy i was the first one out the door i
think my mom was still getting my little
sister ready
and immediately upon exiting our front
door
i must have taken just a couple steps
out admiring my cookie in my hand
when all of a sudden there there was
bushes right in front of our
i guess our apartment apartment door
just about maybe 15 feet away
there was a bushes that lined that area
up
and there was a man that jumped out of
the bushes he had one hand behind his
back
and he and with his other hand he was
like hey come here i have something for
you
come here i have something for you well
i have never seen this man so i was not
i was not anxious to go towards him at
all
and he saw that i wasn't moving and he
kept saying come here i have something
for you so i thought
maybe he wants some of my cookies so i
extended my cookie out to him
and i said would you like a bite and
he's like no i don't want your cookie
i have something for you that you're
gonna love come here
well i wasn't moving alex i was not
moving whatsoever so he began to move
towards me
and right about when he was arm's length
away he removed his other hand from
behind his back
and he had a knife and he said i said
come here
and that exact moment he
was about to grab me when my puerto
rican mother
um walked out of the front door now
i don't know alex if you know any puerto
ricans yes um i've been to puerto rico
four times
okay so you you've been there plenty of
times
i don't know if you've ever seen an
angry puerto rican particularly an
angry mother that's very defensive over
a cubs
a bear this man who was much bigger than
all of us
she sees her son about to be abducted by
this
this guy with a knife in his hand my
mother saw his eyes he saw hers
and that brother turned around and took
off running at my mother
took off running after him now i like to
tell people that he's very lucky that my
mother didn't catch him because she
meant
business yeah well anyways um you know
alex i must have been around seven years
old and can you imagine this like
i have been nearly killed by several of
my own family members
now we finally move out we're on our own
and shortly after we're on our own i'm
almost abducted from our
very own front door by the stranger alex
you know what this did to me
i never wanted to leave my house again
right and security i never want to leave
my mother's presence again
i didn't want to i didn't go out to play
with my friends my cousins outside i was
petrified
all along thinking that this man was
gonna come out
when i least expect her when i'm away
from my mother
and he's gonna finish me off like he
intended to so by their age around seven
or eight years old
i've had to face nearly face death from
my own
flesh and blood and now i'm almost was
abducted and killed by some stranger
and at a very young age i thought what's
the point of living
i thought it probably is better just to
die and end my life
and so that that's how i was early on it
was it was just a traumatic
um childhood i could say to say the very
least for sure
yeah yeah i mean that's like i say you
know uh
i'm sure you didn't want to leave your
house i mean you want to be
insecure uh thinking about these guys
going to show up again
and wow seven years old i mean
yeah i mean youtube i mean seven years
old i mean you can tell
superman exists and you think yeah i
mean you know
i mean you believe in that kind of stuff
right i mean and then can you imagine
something like real
disconnect oh wow
okay yeah and speaking speaking speaking
of superman alex i i
you know i i was all into batman was a
big deal back in
my my childhood in superman and never
once did superman or batman ever
come to my rescue but there was someone
that that did step
into my life that did rescue me to a
certain degree from the
the danger that i was in um when i was
about eight years old my mother
dropped my sister and i at my father's
house
and my father never had a father figure
in his life he was adopted
and so he she drops us off at his house
saying
look i can't i can't afford you know
i've done everything i could i just
can't do this anymore
and so she dropped us off at my father's
house and my father is a very good
christian
um loves the lord and everything and so
when she dropped us off my sister and i
were kind of afraid because we didn't
really have a deep relationship with him
but
he'll he says this later on but he said
david um
that that night when you were dropped
off i went into the room when you all
were asleep and i just prayed to god and
i said lord
i've never had a father in my life i've
never had an example of a good father
but i'm looking to you for your help to
be the best father that i can because
you have never left me
and so i mean when i was practicing you
know how traumatized i was
wow say that again alex no what a trust
you know i mean what a trust i mean
i mean you know i mean it takes like
like you need to go to your needs and
say you know what i mean i got two
children right there
and please guy help me great
yeah um yeah he he was
he was absolutely clueless about how to
raise children
other than the first years obviously
that he raised us and he did a wonderful
job but
you know we were a number of years out
out living with my mother and
anyways alex i was traumatized my father
said i would wake up in the middle of
the night i would start running
around saying please don't leave me stop
leave me alone don't leave me and
my father would have to grab me and hold
on to me and say david i'm right here
i'm not leaving you i'm not leaving you
and so my father saw that i had gone
through so much
and so my dad said david it was i was
we were with him for about a year or two
and my dad said david
i'm gonna you're about to turn 10 years
old i'm going to give you the most
powerful weapon this world has ever seen
i was like are you serious he's like
yeah i'm going to give you the most
powerful weapon the world has ever seen
i'm like you're gonna give me a bazooka
and he's like a bazooka
no it's much more powerful than that and
then i said oh dad you're gonna give me
a grenade launcher
he's like what is that and you know i
kept listing off all these weapons i saw
on tv on our video games
and and he said no david it's gonna be
much more powerful than that
so i remember i turned 10 years old i
was the first one up i woke up my sister
my dad said it's my birthday it's time
to open up the most powerful weapon
and so my dad's a big jokester he likes
to joke a lot
and so he had this huge box and there
must have been 15
or so boxes in that one box and finally
i get
to the actual box where my gift is in
the most powerful weapon
and do you know what it was alex i ended
i ended up opening that gift and here i
am on the screen
10 years old and it was a book
my dad gives me this book it's called
the bible
and i opened it up and it you know i
i wasn't really interested to tell you
to tell you for sure i i mean
to be honest with you it was thousands
of pages no pictures in this
big book and i was thinking 10 years old
you really think how is this
the most powerful weapon and my dad
looked at me i'll never forget this he
said david
this is the most powerful weapon this
world has ever seen this book has saved
more lives
than any of your modern day superheroes
more than batman or superman this book
has the power to save and i know david
this book can help you
and alex i wish that i
would have started reading that book and
and really gotten interested in it but
to be completely honest with you i
didn't open up really with an interested
heart
i didn't open up the bible for another
10 or 11 years after that
wow so that was like another 10 years of
a lot of teenagers years that jesus
was not there you know kind of like uh
how was it how was those thing measured
you know because
you got the bible you got you got the
weapon bro you got the weapon
i got the weapon but the weapon's only
good if you open it up
and let it into your heart just like any
other weapon
you gotta you gotta open up you gotta
put the bullets and you gotta you gotta
engage with it you gotta use it i was
not engaged with the bible whatsoever
and i remember when i was 13 years old
um i had my older cousins invite me over
to their house and
um you know we were celebrating my
birthday at my cousin's house and
they're like all right david hey you're
13 years old you're a man now you want
to spend the night
and these were older cousins i was like
spend the night with you all and they
were like yeah you want to spend the
night i said
man that's awesome yeah i would love to
and so i asked my dad and my dad was
like sure you could you could spend the
night
um you could spend the night with them
and so i was oh
i've always been early to bed early to
rise kind of a guy so it must have been
8 39 o'clock and i was like hey guys
i'm going to bed and they're like going
to bed it's nine o'clock what are you
thinking i said
well it's time to go to bed i'm tired
and he's like
no men don't go to bed at nine o'clock
and i said
well why and they're like no men go to
bed like at 1
2 in the morning i'm like well i don't
know if i want to be a man and so
they're like no
no you're a man now and they took me
over to their computer
i thought they were going to introduce
me to some video game or something
but do you know the very next thing
they threw a dvd into the computer
and i was for the first time in my life
introduced to the world of pornography
now alex this was repulsive to me
i remember as soon as i started seeing
the images and everything i just started
screaming and i started turning away
like i was disgusted of this stuff
yeah but my cousins literally bound me
to the chair
kept my eyes open covered my mouth and
they forced me to watch pornography
forever
long it was it felt like eternity and
from that moment alex
i became addicted to this terrible vice
for the next
eight seven eight years that really just
fed
fed me in all the wrong ways and so by
the age of 13 years old i have gone
through
physical abuse sexual abuse
i i have gone through a lot of terrible
things in alex
i wouldn't want to wish this life upon
anyone but i want to tell you something
instead of turning to the bible for help
instead of turning to god for help i
turned to the only thing that i
that was my god from the very beginning
and that was basketball
basketball was my god it was my idol
that's that i you know this is the
staples center this is where the los
angeles lakers played i would go and
watch them play
my whole life i just wanted to become a
professional basketball player so
in high school i started practicing
every day i started
you know preparing to try to enter into
the
to the nba and i remember
my i believe it was my senior year in
high school
and we were playing the top team in our
division we were ranked
four and they were ranked number one
and we needed to win this game in order
to make it to the playoffs
and the score was 60 to 60 30 seconds
left on the clock
and i remember the coach calls us up to
the huddle it's our possession it's all
our ball and he's and i remember he
looked at us and he said listen
someone's life is about to change and so
i started listening he says do you
understand
there are reporters from different news
stations here in this gym
do you know there are scouts from
different schools in this gym
whoever makes the last shot to win this
game your life will never be the same
again
and alex this was it i mean this is what
i've been waiting for this is what i've
been working for
i thought if i could get to the nba all
my problems all my issues would be
gone well do you know alex
i was a shooting guard in that
particular game i had to hit seven
three-pointers
and i said to the coach give me the ball
and the coach was like made a play they
did it
the point guard took it down all the way
he got down to to um
to half court he threw it to me on top
of the three-point line i heard the
audience
shouting counting down finally it was
down to five
four three i faked the guy like i was
gonna shoot it i put him in a popcorn
machine i ran down the center aisle
i heard two one and right before the
buzzer went off i
let the ball go and you know what
happened
you made it the ball the ball went in
that's right
and the whole stadium came crashing down
um they were lifting me up i was on the
front pages of newspapers i
i had recruiters talking to me about
going to different colleges maybe i
watched that video
what'd you say maybe i watched that
video you know sometimes on youtube you
watch those videos you know like in high
school
yeah you know i wish a family member or
someone was recording it
um i know there was someone recording it
from the opposite team but i'm pretty
sure that they did not put that one on
youtube or anything because they lost um
but it was it was it was in my mind the
greatest day of my life
you know alex whenever i had a
basketball i forgot about all the trauma
and all the pain that i went through
but i want to tell you something alex
yeah a life without jesus is so empty
that's true um you know i had what i
thought everything
the very next day i'm wearing my fancy
leatherman jacket
you know that jacket that you know high
schoolers use they buy it's so expensive
and they never wear it after high school
um i remember i i was walking
senior with my jacket my last name
machado in the back
and i thought i was going to be the talk
of the school everyone was just going to
be talking about all the
class teachers are just going to cancel
their their classes and just talk about
the game that's what i thought was going
to happen
but do you know alex everyone seemed to
have forgotten what happened that day
no one mentioned anything i mean i was
bringing it up to people
i knew everyone was there but it was
like nothing and i thought in my mind
if if this is what life is all about
you win some and you lose some and game
over you may be at the top of the game
to get you're forgotten
i thought how is this even wonderful how
is this even something to be coveted
after
so alex you know what happened instead
of pursuing my dreams of making it
into the nba i just started getting into
more trouble with the law i started
making terrible mistakes i was on
foot races with cops i've had police
helicopters look for me
my senior year in high school instead of
graduating with my graduating class i
was going to be going to jail with a
felony on my record
it was just a living mess alex because
a life without jesus isn't worth living
and finally i had hit rock bottom at the
lowest of my life
and i didn't know what to do with my
life i was ready my first year in
college
had no purpose and no idea what i was
going to do
and something happened
i was given a flyer that changed my life
forever
oh wow let me tell you right up here
before we're gonna go
before we're gonna go today i have
somebody
uh bernice coffee's coffee
yeah yes they yeah she has a newspaper
about it
who is she is your friend that actually
is my mom yeah oh okay
i was like she has that newspaper
yeah my mother has all the newspaper
articles she
framed it put it in a in a book um and
she would show it to me often when i was
like right now yeah of course all right
well
uh you need to take a picture of that
the newspaper
yeah i probably should i i probably
should ask my mother for a copy of it so
that i could
put it on our presentations and stuff
like that yeah that's sure
okay i just want to share that with you
yeah okay so
you were saying that you know uh she was
crazy
and also i mean cops was looking for you
you were doing all these and
crazy stuff but when i watch your videos
on youtube man i mean when i watch your
videos and facebook it's like
are we talking about with two different
people here because that guy
looks so with the big smile uh so kind
i mean so perfect guy you know like
anything went wrong you know but uh now
i hear you
your story and it's like
i mean unbelievable but i cannot yeah i
cannot wait until
that moment uh because
even i mean growing up i mean your
childhood it was
so terrible i mean i'm sorry to say that
but i'm not saying it was so bad because
uh the love of you of your dad and your
mom you know it was there
that it was so traumatic let's put it
that way you know
uh yeah but jesus he was it was later on
um but let's talk about it what happened
when
some flyers show up yeah yeah so
someone ended up giving me a flyer it
looked exactly like this i used to play
basketball with
this guy and he said hey david you got
to go hear this rapper
okay um rap at this church and i used to
love rap music so i was like
this guy's gonna rap at church i'm going
and so
you know at that time i wasn't really
interested in going to church at all
didn't really have a relationship with
god at all
and so when this guy gave me this flyer
talking about some rapper rapping at
church i was like hey that seems kind of
interesting
so i thought i was going to go to a rap
concert at church
and boy was i wrong i remember i get to
this church
walk in it's completely packed huge
church
and i see this tall african-american guy
bald head goatee
in a suit and i thought man i never seen
a rapper wrapped in a suit before
this is going to be interesting you
cannot wait so i remember
that's right how is he going to do that
so i remember i just was
waiting for him to rap but that brother
didn't rap at all he just shared his
testimony
and the brother basically said in the
early 90s he turned out an 800
000 contract because he found god
i mean he was on bet he was on rap city
mtv he was on all these
major stations about to make it big in
his life
and you know what
he said he was willing to give it all up
because he found god
and i thought what is this guy doing in
my mind i thought
money was the ticket out of a terrible
dramatic life and he turned it all down
because he found jesus christ
so i started listening at first i was
really angry because he wasn't wrapping
any
any lyrics or anything and but now he
got my attention so i started listening
to him
at the very end alex i was so moved
that
i'm tossing by jesus christ and he made
an altar call
he says whoever would like to accept
jesus as your personal savior come to
the front
this was on march 5th 2007 and i thought
to my mind
there's no way there's no way god would
even want me i've gone too far i've done
too many bad things
what would god do with me i'm a nobody
i have nothing to offer him i'm nothing
but a big sinner
and i remember these thoughts started
coming through my mind
and you know alex that was the devil
just whispering in my ear just as he's
whispering to maybe some of your
listeners today
saying that you know what's the point of
living just give up
your you don't have a purpose in life
just give up
you know no one loves you those kind of
thoughts were going through my mind and
immediately alex when those
the devil was whispering those things in
my mind the next thing that preacher
said was
it doesn't matter what your reputation
is it doesn't matter what you've done
god loves you he wants you and he and he
has a purpose for you right now
just come to the front and alex instead
of walking reverently to the front i
ran to the front i ran over there and i
i just surrendered my life to the lord
jesus christ on march 5th 2007
marked the best day of my life alex i
didn't know any bible verses but i knew
of a god that gave his life for me and i
wanted to get to know him
and so that was like the turning point
in my life and it was just incredible
i'll never forget that day hey man i
mean you don't i mean you don't forget
those dates right i mean
like you baptism you get married or
something major things you know and i
mean if
if i actually like what was the date or
what day
it was uh of that game
the basketball game i'm sure you could
tell me oh that was friday night
this yeah you know i probably
i i could probably tell you what day of
the week it was
but i have no idea what day of the i
don't even know
i know it was in probably 2005 okay but
you know what alex
somehow i've forgotten all those things
back that happened to me
yeah but i'll never forget those things
that really meant something to me like
accepting christ into my life like like
paul
when he says you know i look back at
those things as
as rubbish and i look i press toward the
mark
that's exactly how it's been for me like
the that old life
was just a waste of time i've i've
forgotten it i've been healed from it
and
you know there's so many things that god
did from that starting point march 5th
2007 to today
that are just miracle stories of what
how god changed my heart how he's
changing my heart how he's led
that have just been absolutely
incredible so i have this question for
you
uh sure so how god changed your life you
know i know you've been
telling all these stuff you know i mean
oh what you went through what you
say you know what i'm here lord uh
because
god changed his heart so he can trust
you
over here for the ministry you're gonna
be
because and the moment that you went
over there like you know what lord
here i am you were not thinking you're
going to be in front of the church
and share uh scripture you're going to
share
hope to other people that are you know
going through the difficulties you know
what you work through yeah
so tell us yeah i mean honestly
there was this piece that i i received
that night
that i've never experienced in my whole
life there was this peace that
that just flooded my soul at that moment
that i never wanted it to leave me
alex i couldn't sleep at night i would i
would i would see things running at me
i was traumatized alex all my life
and it wasn't until that moment where i
experienced this peace
someone hugging me and tugging my heart
just saying david i'm here i'm not i've
never left you
and i'm here to change you i'm here to
help you
and alex it was the most life-changing
beautiful experience i've ever had
[Music]
wow amen i'm gonna say is basically at
that moment
i had really no knowledge of the
scripture you know for like 10 years i
didn't pick up the bible to read it from
my own interest
and so i had a lot of questions so i
started asking people at the church i
was like hey i got a lot of questions
does anyone could study with me and
there was this guy by the name of mike
and i was introduced to him and and man
he started giving me bible studies
every single night it seemed like and i
would stay at this house till
very late almost till the morning
remember i'm not a a late
night owl but it was it was incredible i
was getting answers to
if there is a god why if there is a good
god why do bad things
happen to good people and and getting
all my questions
answered that i had and he had this
little ministry that that he traveled
with and he asked me to join him and
he said david you'll be able to share
your testimony you'll be able to share
what god has done for you and you'll be
able to preach and alex at that time
public speaking was my number one fear i
hated it
never wanted to be a public speaker
pastor teacher nothing i hated
being in front of people i just despised
it didn't like it
and now i'm being i'm joining this
little ministry and i'm
you know very quickly being introduced
to how to do this now
i have to say this this was my first
year
in college it was a public university
and i was taking a speech class because
i wanted to
um overcome the fear of public speaking
and during this time it was so it was
almost
more than halfway done with the semester
and we were going to be giving our most
important speech it was a persuasive
speech
now alex this was crazy because
the the teachers up there asking okay
what do you want to talk about what do
you want to persuade us about they got
to me and i said
i'm going to persuade you all that the
love of god is real
now alex i just met god like
maybe 10 days before you know
you know before you know after this guy
asked me this so i just
hardly knew anything and now i'm telling
this public school
public college i'm about to my
persuasive speech my most important
speech
is going to be persuading you all that
god's love is real
now i was no idea what i was going to do
but i was so in love with christ
at that moment i just that's all i
wanted to talk about that's right and so
the day came when i was giving that
public speech
the most scary one of the most scariest
days of my life
and i remember i'm standing before this
huge class or this class and
i went up it was an eight-minute speech
at the end of the eight minutes
alex people were crying
i remember there was this buddhist guy
that came up to me after the class
period he said hey david
i could tell that christ is real because
of you and your testimony in your life
can you study with me the bible can you
share with me about this christ
it was so incredible that i i started a
um
a christian club for the university to
study with people from all walks of life
and here i am you know feeling the call
to public ministry
doing the very thing i was most
petrified of doing
and it was just absolutely incredible i
i loved every moment of it and you know
some people alex think that as soon as
they accept christ into the life life is
going to be easy
oh it's going to be peachy and rosy and
you never have to stress out again
alex i want to tell you something the
moment you decide to choose christ in
your life
the devil is going to attack yeah but
the bible says greater is he that is in
us than he that is in the world
and i remember i was changing my
my my music i was changing those things
and
i asked a friend if i could borrow a
blank cd because i just purchased some
music and i wanted to put it on a cd and
i i put the cd
into my computer i was about to burn
some music when all of a sudden guess
what was on that cd
preaching it was not blank that's that
cd was a dvd and it had pornography
oh and alex it was as if my whole life
just came crashing down upon me i felt
like
i felt so dirty i felt so sick i felt so
sinful
i remember i fell down to the ground i
pulled that dvd out broke it in pieces
and i said god
do whatever it takes to give me victory
over this thing i cannot do it by myself
it's like coming at me it's coming after
me and i can't run away from it
god help me yeah amen
and about two days later
find myself in the hospital
i can't breathe i wake up early in the
morning can't breathe i feel like
there's a knife penetrating my right
side
and my father takes me to the hospital
what happened i had a spontaneous
pneumothorax which means my right
my right lung collapsed spontaneously no
medical reason whatsoever
and i remember i'm taken to my room
doctor so i could be there for weeks my
mother was there and i said mom you're
not going to leave me right she said no
i'm going to be right here by your side
and i thought that's good at least i
won't be alone in this place the nurse
came and said visiting hours are not
over your mom's got to go
and um my mom looked at her said i'm not
a visitor
i'm his mother and i said that's right
my mom even gave birth to me in this
very hospital she the nurse looked at
both of us and she said i'm sorry
you're no longer in the children's
hospital anymore you gotta leave she was
pointing to my mother
so i literally took my mother out and
alex i felt so
alone here i am i just accepted christ
into my life
i thought life was supposed to be
getting better i thought life was
supposed to be getting easier
now i'm in the hospital all alone i can
i have one lung that works the other one
doesn't
and i thought god where are you what's
going on
and alex i began to cry
i felt so alone and maybe there's some
people today
that they may be serving the lord jesus
christ or they may have a relationship
with christ and yet
they're feeling the attacks they're
feeling attacked like i was that day
i remember alex i put a towel over my
face and i began to cry
and i heard a voice the voice was clear
it
said david and alex i was like is this
god speaking to me
again i heard david
i thought i think this is god so i was
about to respond alex
when all of a sudden i felt someone
touched me on my arm and i said is the
lord touching me too
so i took the the towel off of my face
and i thought it was gone and
you know it was it was my pastor
and i looked at him and i said man i
thought you were god
and uh he was like no i'm not god
but i do have a message from god
he says david i just want to let you
know
that god has not left you amen he is
right here by your side he will not
leave you
david and in fact this trial that you're
going through is going to lead you
closer to him
oh alex do you know what that did to me
dude that's praising god man
wow alex i was so thrilled i
i mean right on time this
pastor shows up right in the moment of
my darkest despair my christian walk
and he tells me a message from god alex
you know how excited i was
the very next morning i have to tell you
this i don't know if you've ever i had a
tube
connected into my lung right on my side
to machine i picked up my machine
early that morning and i said i'm gonna
go visit
my neighbor so in my room there was a
curtain right
you've been in the hospital there's
usually a curtain that separates you and
the other patients
i opened that current up and there was
this guy there that uh
had open heart surgery his chest was
still open
and i'm like whoa and he's like waking
up he's like who are you and i'm like
oh my name is david i'm your neighbor
and
um can i sing you a song
and he's like what i'm like yeah can i
sing you a song i have one long alex
and i got this machine i'm like can i
sing you a song so i sing him a
scripture song
and alex that man begins to cry
he begins to weep and he says young man
i don't know what you know i don't know
but i don't think you know what this
means to me
he says i've been in here for months and
this is the first time in months that i
feel like i have
hope thank you so much
alex you know what i did great
i grabbed my machine and i went across
the room
i left my room i went to the next room
and there was two ladies in there i'm
like good morning everybody
and i start singing to them
i start singing to them and they start
crying and they say young man
what are you doing what's wrong with you
i said well i got one lung but i want
with that one lung
i want to praise the lord he's given me
life he's given me breath he's giving me
all things
they began to cry alex and they said you
know what young man we've been in here
for a while and this is the first time
we've ever had
feel like we have hope thank you so much
alex is off it's often times during our
darkest times in life
often times during our darkest times of
light
where we could share the greatest amount
of light i like to tell people our
greatest disappointments in life
can be our greatest appointments with
god
and alex i was discharged out of the
hospital earlier than expected
my lung improved faster than anyone
thought imaginable
and from that day on alex i knew that no
matter what happens in my life
god will always be there for me praise
god
amen so immediately after that
experience
i went on my first mission trip to the
philippines
alex you know how public speaking was my
number one fear
yeah i was now speaking to over a
thousand young people
and this is where i felt convicted that
this is what god wants me to do for the
rest of my life
and alex it was the greatest
i i felt like i had purpose i felt like
i had peace
but i want to tell you something i want
to tell you about a dream i had
in this dream i dreamt
that i was in heaven in the city of god
the new jerusalem
and after the thousand years we were
coming back down to earth
and after that i remember
seeing the wicked resurrected revelation
chapter 20 and i
saw through those transparent walls
someone on the other side
i saw my little sister lost
and i knew that she was lost
because of me because of my terrible
example that i
that i lived for so long and alex it was
the worst experience i've ever had in my
life
i don't know if you've ever had a
nightmare and
in your nightmare you are literally
crying you're literally
literally weeping well alex
i woke up and my tears were literally
coming down my face it was so real
i remember i walked over to my sister's
room
knelt over her and i began to pray i
said god if there is one person i could
win to you if i could win one person two
god
let it be my sister please and alex
after several months later this is my
sister right here on the screen
she gives her life to the lord jesus
christ wow
praise god and it it was amazing now
alex i want to tell you something
serving the lord jesus christ life just
keeps getting better and better
look at this next picture do you know
who this is right here
this next picture here that is my sweet
mother
i was doing an evangelistic series in
the very town that she lived in
um and that's you i had the about
what'd you say you baptized her that's
you i baptized my own mother i like to
tell people alex
that my mother held me when i was born
but i held her when i when she was born
again
and um yeah she i was did a
bible prophecy series she came to the
meeting and at the very end of the
meeting she decided
to accept christ into her life and alex
it has been a dream serving the lord
jesus christ
is like a sweet marriage that that you
never have to say
good night to you never have to say
goodbye jesus is always there
i've been married for almost six years
we're about to have our first child
literally alex in about 10 days is the
due date
um we're about to have our first child
and i want to tell you something alex
there is nothing better than knowing
jesus
it doesn't matter what any one of your
viewers is struggling with
if they lived a drug abusive life if
they've
been sexually abused drug abused they
feel like they have no purpose alex
jesus can give you an identity he could
give you a purpose
do you know alex the very family member
that harmed me the most that nearly
killed me
i remember all i could think about as a
child was getting bigger so i could kill
him
i want to tell you something alex when i
accepted christ into my life
god gave me a supernatural love for him
god basically told me david nobody could
ever do
the amount of evil to you
that you have done to me and
yet i love you i forgive you go do the
same
i started studying with my family member
alex that family member went to go drug
rehab
he went over and gave his life to the
lord jesus christ and for the last 10
years he's been going to different
prisons all over
talking about how jesus has set him free
my worst enemy became my best one of my
best friends
that is the power of the gospel and
that's what jesus can do for everyone
wow i mean your story is like i mean i
didn't i didn't expect that
i mean that's a do you have a book i
mean
[Laughter]
that's that's that's incredible and let
me tell you guys
right now uh please i'm gonna take this
time because brother david has a
ministry i'm gonna be sharing
uh he has a youtube channel you can be
blessed
watching his videos uh uh
i'm gonna share that with you right now
please go go visit his youtube channel
uh called revelation of love of course
you know of love for god yeah what he
was sharing
preaching at the college uh
revelation love ministry please go uh on
youtube
and give you some love you know
subscribe and watch it and share it
share these
small clips that he has and i'm sure
it's gonna be powerful ones
uh videos i really been blessed
uh and videos and also uh
uh you have um a website right you can
they find out more about about about the
videos yeah right right on the screen
there's a website right there
it's called revelationlove.com people
could go there and
we have presentations there we have
bible study guides
um you can look at our schedule where
i'm gonna be preaching at next
we do classes um we do all kinds of
stuff people could subscribe to our
newsletter
to find out where we're at what we're
doing right there on revelation love dot
com
they can email us at info revelation of
love dot com and
you get a hold of me we would love to
hear from you all yeah
that's great uh please please go support
uh
bro david and let me tell you guys i
mean
you guys gonna be no just listen
a person i'm i'm not saying you know
professional
seminars and any other stuff they don't
do but
i mean you had a story of i love story
this you know i love story how jesus say
you know what for these
mess i'm gonna bring you love and
and then about you you your enemy become
your best friend i mean
wow just wow god is good right
a merciful god yes powerful god yes a
personal god
amen wow amen i've been blessed man i
mean i'm looking at you
i didn't know your story thank you so
much for sharing here and just be
blessed
i mean thank you so much for having me
i've been blessed to be able to share
god's goodness with you
amen amen so i have two questions for
you before we're going to wrap
this up uh one please share with us your
favorite bible verse
i'm sure it's many right come on share
with us
yeah i have my bible here okay uh but i
have
a lot but i think the one of them that
speak the most to me it's found in a
very small book
it's in micah chapter 7 verse 7
and it says therefore i will look unto
the lord
i will wait for the god of my salvation
my god will hear me
rejoice not against me or my enemy when
i fall i shall rise when i sit in
darkness
the lord shall be a light unto me i love
this bible text because it shows that
if we just look to god we will find him
no matter how far we've fallen
he is there to bring us out of darkness
into his marvelous light
wow amen amen powerful thank you so much
and what is your final thoughts
and i know you've been you've been
talking to the audience you know
if you listen this story and stuff like
that but please share with us
your final thoughts i mean how growing
up and those
difficult times and and you were feeling
those the emptiness and the the you need
love
i mean you went through sports and then
addiction or pornography and
and i don't know if it was drugs there
or not but i mean it was it was crazy in
those moments
eight years block boom right eight years
until jesus show up uh please share with
us your final plus
for those people that are watching your
story well well first of all
i want to say that um
you can do all things through christ who
strengthens you you could do nothing
without christ
i was able to rise above the abuse only
because of christ and he
turned my mess of a life into a message
and so i want to share with all of you
that are there right now
that are listening if you are struggling
with pornography
if you're struggling with abuse in the
past
don't let it define your present jesus
could give you a fresh start he could
allow you to rise above the abuse and
have
true freedom forever if you are
struggling with um
abuse if you are struggling with the
addiction of pornography or anything for
that matter
please reach out to me um go to our
website
i have different series on how to
overcome
abuse how to overcome the addiction of
pornography
and so do feel free to reach out to us
we will be more than happy to help you
out
and to encourage you to find victory in
jesus christ
so don't give up just give in to the
spirit of god
and find the freedom that only he can
give amen amen
thank you so much once again brother
david uh
uh i was blessed seriously i was i was
so blessed listen your story and i'm
sure
those people they're gonna be blessed
too uh
please don't hang up i'm gonna finish
this video okay
sounds good all right uh okay guys i
hope you were blessed because
it was amazing story i didn't expect
that it was it was amazing
how good a merciful god until you think
it's all
crazy your life gonna bless you
god's gonna return change that
uh painful painful life
and something amazing but let me tell
you thank you so much for your support
here and just be blessed
and this video is going to be available
next week in our youtube channel
if you haven't subscribed or something
go enjoy those stories people's stories
and i've left the messages
go subscribe and thanks so much for your
love
here in our youtube channel and also uh
patreon
if you would love to uh support us
here in just be blessed uh please be a
patreon and
so i would like to build some websites
and i
to bring more more more things for for
you guys
uh thanks so much for your support and
my name is alex castillejos here and
just be blessed
and i just want to say thank you so much
for for being here and i will see you
next week bye